– Also, Sie wollen sich
auf eine Stelle bewerben.
– Das ist richtig.
– Wo?
– In einem Fast-Food-Restaurant.
– Okay.
– Papa ist eigentlich Arzt,
aber er muss noch
eine Sprachprüfung bestehen,
damit er in Deutschland arbeiten darf.
– Selma …
– Was denn?
– Das geht niemanden etwas an.
– Lisa will dir helfen, Papa.
– Also, Sie müssen zuerst dort anrufen
und danach gibt es noch ein
persönliches Gespräch. Richtig?
– Ja, richtig.
– Gut, dann zuerst der Anruf.
Was würden Sie sagen?
– Guten Tag,
hier spricht Ibrahim Al-Pascha.
– Mhm.
– Ich rufe an, weil ich mich
bei Ihnen bewerben möchte.
– Auf welche Arbeitsstelle?
– Restaurant-Mitarbeiter.
– Okay. Fragen Sie nach einem Termin
für ein Bewerbungsgespräch.
– Ich möchte wissen, ob ich einen Termin
für ein Gespräch haben kann.
– Lieber: Können Sie mir sagen,
wie ich einen Termin für ein
Bewerbungsgespräch bekomme?
Das klingt höflicher.
– Okay. Soll ich … noch meine Quali…
– ... Qualifikationen sagen?
Nur wenn man Sie danach fragt.
Ansonsten ist das ein Thema für das
Bewerbungsgespräch.
– Dafür müssen wir uns
auch noch vorbereiten.
Kennst du zufällig jemanden, der weiß,
wie Bewerbungsgespräche ablaufen?
– Vielleicht kenne ich sogar einen
Geschäftsführer,
der häufig Bewerbungsgespräche führt.